un visage rond ou ovale et de grands
yeux expressifs dessiner un manga ça
s'apprend mariko est japonaise et
dessinatrice elle devient aujourd'hui
professeur de manga pour ces jeunes de
guyancourt on peut savoir beaucoup de
choses dans le manga moi aussi j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses de la vie par
manga l'émotion est là sont des gens et
quand ça peut permettre un accès
facilement dans le manga jusqu'au
vendredi on va essayer de réaliser
chacun petit manga je suis une page et
ils vont inventer le personnage chez
chacun et puis on va répéter le scénario
arrivé en france dans les années 90 le
manga s'est taillé une place de choix
dans la culture populaire
douze adolescents participent à cet
atelier youth hairaz et sa soeur sont
venus perfectionner leur technique
moi j'en ai déjà dessiné mais je ne
connaissais pas et technique
donc là je venais ici pour en apprendre
plus tu es beaucoup mieux avec les
techniques parce qu'avant c'était pas
très facile le dessin c'est pas trop mon
truc mais j'ai et après quand j'ai eu ma
soeur à la dia stage manga j' ai dit bon
bah je vais juste essayer mais là quand
je fais je lis amusant donc j'aime bien
au delà de l'aspect artistique ce stage
se veut une découverte culturelle du
japon la semaine sera ponctuée
d'ateliers cuisine et calligraphie pour
tout connaître sur le pays du soleil
levant